[Music]
right that's the last matinee show of
the year matinee episode 65 yeah pretty
good one so yeah we're actually gonna do
a Netflix original series two movies in
the theater and since it's the last show
of the year I'm also going to and maybe
Tom wants to do this too but I'm also
gonna give my top ten movies of the year
okay cuz I already sorted that out
alright so the first yeah the first one
we're gonna talk about now this was
recommended by a fan we were gonna watch
it anyway you know but we've decided to
get around to it
quicker this is the Netflix docu-series
don't [ __ ] with cats yeah hunting an
internet killer about that schipper yeah
we actually did a show about this guy um
not entirely about this guy but that it
was that Canadian crime when we did like
several weeks back and we talked about
him his name is Luca man yada ya boy man
well this is it's actually a three-part
miniseries and it's less focused on Luca
man yada which is good because he's a
[ __ ] attention [ __ ] in like you know
yeah attention yeah he was a compliment
he wasn't a complicated character that's
why he was doing what he was doing he
there's really not too good that's yeah
that's what I mean it's like if you have
to resort to that kind of [ __ ] to get
attention then clearly there's nothing
to you right
it was mostly kind of centered on Deanna
Thompson who is a she was a data analyst
from Las Vegas and then this other guy
that she met online named John Green and
how these two people you know they saw
the initial videos of Luca manana
killing the kittens yeah you know one
point two kittens I think that we did
with a vacuum cleaner and stuff yeah I'm
in the bathtub and feeding one to a
Python yeah various other things but
yeah so they saw this video and they
kind of made it their mission in life to
find out who the [ __ ] this person was
yeah and so it's almost kind of like
even though you know how you know you
know how it happened if you know
anything about Luca manana like you know
yes later he went on and killed a person
but I think it's almost kind of like
it's set up almost a little bit like a
mystery story because and it's kind of
fast
how these two people because they had
like a Facebook group with like
thousands and thousands of members as
well yeah cat lovers you know that mean
anything it's like they pretty much were
just like we're gonna [ __ ] find this
guy they were doing some like FBI level
investigation they were investigating
every frame of videos that he put out
photos and they figured out where this
guy was they tried to call the law and
laud him on do anything because they
were just well jurisdictions and you
know it might be fake and there's just a
bunch of different reasons and they were
like you got to get rid of this dude man
he's gonna kill a person and he did kill
a person thank you know called it yep
well that's anybody one that anybody
that would kill two kittens in that
fashion and worse yet someone that would
put it on the [ __ ] Internet and then
like he also like went under all these
different sock puppet accounts and he
would like go in their Facebook group
and like troll them and stuff yeah and
then make nothing but videos about
himself and fake neuter news articles
about himself and he would comment on
his own news articles he's trying to
make a big ol he wanted to be a model
you know he wanted to be famous and yeah
just trying to make his own media
company that just talked about him like
he did some kids he photoshopped a bunch
of pictures to his face on other
people's which is dumb because it's like
you know Google has a reverse image
search you can really it's very easy to
find someone you also put a KitKat the
cage poured gasoline on it set it on
fire that's that's another one so yeah
you need tape a cat to the end of a
stick and stick it down in the bathtub
you know in the water dry you know um
more cats looking at the camera like hey
where's this window why my face it's
like I was kind of like this is what I
had to do you guys I mean you know I
love cats yeah
probably more than people generally well
oh it's like there's certain people that
got to go just saying yeah but so I I
have to say that it's like I wanted to
see this because I'm fascinated by this
douche but I was like I had to skip
through it I was like they're not gonna
show like the whole videos are they cuz
I don't think I could watch it not even
sure they but they showed enough of it
that if you're the situation if you're
really sensitive to this kind of stuff
you might want to skip it because they
do show what's gonna happen what's gonna
happen they show the audio or they have
the odd
they have Deanna Thompson the one of the
women that helped find him
she's like narrating it yeah like she's
saying what's happening and they also
show like the aftermath because
apparently he put up a video of him
playing with the two dead kittens and
they do show that yeah and they do show
a picture of that so yes just know that
before you get into it they don't show
the entire video they don't show the
kittens dying he also killed that puppy
after he killed that guy yeah - that's
it and then that police detective
started crying when she tried to
describe what he did the puppy she never
got around to saying what he did the
father how do we want to know yeah I
don't want to know if you can make a
[ __ ] police detective yeah yeah yeah
cry yeah that's [ __ ] up yeah that's
[ __ ] up and not in a good way I was
she was funny is that there really
wasn't anything to the guy that's what I
mean so what it is he kind of have this
he's almost kind of like a natural
disaster you have this nonentity doing
this yeah now his mom gets on there and
defends him and think it says he was a
puppet to another guy who was making him
do it Annie yeah I don't believe any of
that [ __ ] I don't either and they point
this out in the docu-series that man
Jana was like really into you like you
said he was very into like surface level
[ __ ] he was always like pulling stunts
that he got from movies and stuff and
they pointed out they said you know his
favorite movie was Basic Instinct he
even had like a like a little [ __ ]
yeah bring of it everything he'll wanna
beat Sharon Sharon Stone yeah and the
guy like that he kept saying was like
controlling when the guy that the mom
kept saying was controlled because his
mom's batshit crazy so I have to say I
she can okay are you watching or I'll be
watching you [ __ ] crazy yeah it's
like get help seriously because she's
batshit she's bad jeans she's batshit
crazy as he is so well obviously not as
bad cuz I don't think she's killed
anybody
yeah that weed that we know of but um
she was she seemed real superficial
though - yeah so it's like the story
that he came up with about this Manny
person it was like oh we forced him
forced him to do these things like
off-camera or he was gonna kill him or
some other kind of crap um that pretty
much like the name and everything they
pretty much took it from either Basic
Instinct or another movie like there was
somebody there when
when he fed the kitten to the Python you
can and there was yeah there was another
person but that might have been just the
person that owned the Python yeah and
they never found the Python it was to
ever own the Python that's what I think
because like all the other videos like
you didn't really see anybody else in
them um but that one there was another
hand in there and I'm assuming that that
was the guy I thought it wasn't said hey
yeah yeah it's like yes I know pythons
eat mice and rats and they eat little
animals yeah yeah yeah the animals all
eat each other but this is all an
artificial I mean and cats are pets yeah
you know I mean knock it off yeah and
later pets and like I said just it
there's one thing it's like you know I I
read about serial killers all day long
stuff like that it's like [ __ ] serial
killers are bad enough but then ones
that have to go and be a [ __ ] edge
lord about it it's like that just like
that just like makes me yeah all that
much some people might say well rats are
pets and you feed rats to this yes but
rats are a dime a dozen there's lots of
them they don't have much personality
and humans never raised rats to be pets
yeah yeah I mean it although rats are
really smart and if you get like pet
ones yeah like they're kind of you know
they're not very they're not that
sophisticated they're not like a cat
though they're it's just not like a cat
it's just not the same it's not the same
kind of person that I still wouldn't
want to watch a video that some [ __ ]
chode put up it's like watch my foot
funny but why the [ __ ] I seen lots of
that I have to why a feeder it mostly I
know they most guys most guys get dead
rats they're frozen rats yeah when they
get little pinkies they call them like
that's for small but when I was a kid
coming up you know they were just you go
to the pet store and they were just huge
huge boxes filled with rats and mice
there yeah food yeah their food but
those rats and right mice don't live
very long there they're raised in
captivity very quickly there's high
turnover they live in that cage their
whole life there are only a few weeks
old
there's no mice you know man they don't
know what they're missing out there's
simply like little robots to have a pet
gecko and he had to
he ate roaches crickets mealworms
mealworms stuff like that so I had to
like raise cricket and that's happening
though that's happening in the wild but
rat but snakes aren't really Bo
constrictors and pythons they're not
eating cats yeah and they're not really
part of their it's not that's not their
normal and like I said they will do it
but that's not their normal and the fact
that this guy was just like doing this
[ __ ] like for Tipton's show off and like
I said he's round one and he killed that
guy's puppy to gene the guy he was all
vice on yeah he's all nice to the camp
inhe and then gave it to the [ __ ] yeah
it's [ __ ] up and it's like how to [ __ ]
that do that like I said it's like it's
it's good to see it because you can see
what kind of horrible people are they're
out in the world but I have a hard time
watching it it's like it's pretty
upsetting
yeah and he's trying to be sexy as [ __ ]
when he's doing this I mean you look at
the dude you he's not normal you know
dude's malfunctioning welcoming but he
had to be put down that dude if somebody
got to him before he killed that dick
gay Chinese kid you'd have an extra
person walking around yeah in a way it's
like I can see kind of both sides of it
it's like I can understand how
frustrated like um you know Deana John
that the two people are tracking him
down I can understand how frustrated
they works they're like look there's
this psycho and we know where he is he's
in Toronto they even know what [ __ ]
building he lived in yeah
because they identified it like they
they weighed out where he was they
figured out where he was cuz there was
like a picture of him that he posted
like on Instagram or something and they
went through the entire City of Toronto
trying man like mangrove maps like they
just like did a whole walkthrough until
they [ __ ] find that background yeah
he took a picture of himself out on the
balcony and in the background you could
see the arrangement all the buildings
yeah you could see like a gas station so
they said oh okay how many of those gas
stations are in Toronto how many Thea
then they had to like go around it like
fine
but this is a review of the series we
got a state it's a good series go ahead
and watch it
like I said if you're sensitive to
cruelty to animals it's like there might
be some points you might not have more
if you liked the show if you like our
normal shows and you'd probably like
that one yeah and we did a show about
this [ __ ] jackal so you should like
go watch that too but yeah it's a really
good it's only three episodes like I
said it plays out like a mystery and I
just love that these two people were
like
like the the clever [ __ ] that they did
like to find with like they [ __ ]
track his vacuum cleaner that was in the
back great as it was [ __ ] just like it's
like 4chan trying to track down Shia
LeBoeuf that's how they didn't worry
what it just take his hat what was it we
turn a picture to take something from it
some kind of flag is funny oh I don't
know I don't know yeah but um so in a
way it's like I like that they called
this don't [ __ ] with cats because it
just goes to show you it's like you do
something bad to a cat and people will
go to them I mean these two they just
like spent their entire mean they had
jobs and stuff but it's like they spent
all of their free time looking for this
guy and they found him yeah and you know
I mean and if the police had listened to
them then Lind would still be alive but
you know they didn't know they just the
cops didn't know but you know but it's a
good show it's on Netflix at the moment
so go
you
all right and we actually got our butts
to the theater yes aw Jumanji yeah next
level yeah we rented the first one
because we hadn't seen the first one I
had never seen the person I saw the
original that came out in 1995 but I
remember almost nothing about it yeah I
don't think it was that remarkable I
remember its but I've just again
whatever I don't think I was really the
target market for this for the time I
think it was mostly a kids movie yeah
I'm like I said I don't remember all I
remember is the board game and animals
running around and Robin lanes getting
in it that's all I right yeah I'm going
dressed like Teddy Roosevelt see I don't
even think it was anyway um rented the
first one the first one was great said
Carson was actually much better than he
expecting it was Ali was a lot of fun we
sat around with some drinks the more I
[ __ ] had a great time and then the
next day we saw part two next level and
it was good too I enjoyed it I enjoyed
him there it almost kind of like
throwback movies like 80s action
adventure movies everything from that
era just kind of thrown in there you
know what I mean together cuz it's
happening inside a video game so you got
to Maury durand Raiders of the Lost Ark
and Mad Max type stuff go on in it's
just fun movie all-star cast yeah I will
say um like I like I like the first one
better the first one was funnier but the
second one was pretty funny too and I
mean I like that it seems like a really
crowd-pleasing yes sequel it's already
made like [ __ ] one four hundred
million dollars already or something
like that it's nowhere near as weak as a
lot of sequels can be though that's yeah
oh yeah that's good it's almost as good
it's almost as good I like the first one
slightly more they just kind of redo the
same thing over again yeah it's like
pretty much the only thing I mean if you
look whistle if you saw the first one
where it's like you know the kind of the
main characters and they all go in with
their avatars and stuff I think the
reason that I like the first one better
is because I got used to to those
characters in those avatars like I get
used to like Alex Wolf's character being
in the rock and then I got rid you know
you get used to like you know Bethenny
being check black or whatever it was so
it's like you kind of get used to that
so the the sequel you know the game is
the game is malfunctioning yeah so you
know you have
the different characters and different
things it's like Bethany isn't in it for
quite a while which was kind of a bummer
because I kind of liked your character
but um you know in Danny DeVito and
Danny Glover in it there's like an
addition like Danny DeVito is like Alex
Wolf's is characters yeah grandfather
yeah and Danny Glover is like a guy that
he used to work with or they they were
like best friends and there's like so
there's like a you know that it's kind
of about that those two guys
ending their friendship yeah they're
kind of like the main focus of the movie
as two old men in a video games do an
old men what old men do when they when
they play video games yeah just it's
just like [ __ ] things these are these
are real old guys funny because in this
one like Danny DeVito is the brave stone
avatars rock for a long time yes so the
old man they get a lot of comic mileage
out of that it but I have to say though
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] um the the one
guy that's look [ __ ] what's his name
Kevin Hart that plays that played the
other guy and Danny Glover is in his
avatar he's like them what is he he's
not the map reader he's like the [ __ ]
oh he's backpack guy he's the guy that
carries everybody else's [ __ ] mouths I
think he also becomes a Chinese thief
girl well yeah I was gonna get to that
but as but that but Kevin my dad was
Danny Danny dude yeah Kevin Hart
channeling Danny Glover yeah was
fantastic that was even funnier than the
rock channeling Danny DeVito I thought I
mean him just mate like cuz you know how
Danny Glover has that kind of like
delicious gambling kind of and like they
really kind of like milked that for all
it was worth like he was because he's
the zoologist so he's like sitting there
going these beautiful mandrels are but
he would just go on and on about getting
killed because he would take so long to
a shot because he was so like [ __ ] it
laid back and and it was just like that
was like super funny but then like later
on there's like a new character
introduced I think her name is Ming
Fleetfoot I think is the character she's
a Chinese thief and for a while
she's played by awkwafina and for a
while Danny DeVito is in her character
and that was hilarious
yes she channeled Danny she really did
advice and everything the facial
expression I could have watched the
whole movie just with her baby pretend
to be and I sound like I was but I
watched one like review of it and
somebody in the comments said Aquafina
makes it better Danny DeVito Danny
really dead like she's hot like she was
all like hunched everybody
yeah but watching these two movies back
to back man I just might have to go in
there and change the [ __ ] masculine
pecking order amongst you know some of
my legendary heroes of the past you know
Arnold and you know Sylvester Stallone
and the cross oh and man the rock is
just moving ahead I'm just I'm just
gaining his man crush engage early man
crush major man crush on the rock just
as a man is so [ __ ] nice and he seems
like a delight very not it seems to be
very nice
well he's very creative he's very
artistic he can act
he's [ __ ] strong and he's strong and
he's I think he might be my age think
he's about 50 he might be might be a
little bit older maybe a year - older
man he looks good for his age yeah
that's a handsome man and he's a dragon
and he's in really good like a
ridiculous and he's you know he and he's
just cool and he's producing good [ __ ] I
love Shazam and you know he'd been
fighting with my family like I really
dug that I think that was kind of like
an underrated he kind of has the
physical physicality of Arnold but then
he kind of has the creativity and acting
skills I think of Sylvester Stallone
well I guess the cool thing about him is
that because we were talking about this
when we were coming home from the movie
um I feel like the rock has more of like
you know nothing against Arnold but
Arnold is very stiff so that's why he
plays good robots and he plays good
stuff like that
whereas the rock is more he's much more
personable and like his keys like
character comes across like no matter
what parties playing yeah I like to put
it this way the Arnold is a very kind of
steely cold character he's good at
playing an archetype yeah you know I
mean he's not really good at playing
like the dude that you know from the bar
yeah okay like a regular guy yeah that's
why he knocked it out of the park in t1
that was Arnold's really for me that was
his best right the she didn't play more
villains they don't want to play
villains I cannae make so grateful he
really does him in that damn punk rock
outfit with this with the with the
spas-12 in one hand and the damn what
was that thing it was a AR that [ __ ]
AR 180 and the other shooting up the
police station the way he's moving with
those glasses and that spiky hair that
was the he just looked badass he sold it
even though I even though I loved his
Conan you know he was great in predator
1 he was he was great he's great as as
Dutch yeah he ducks was his best acting
as far as acting yeah I think that I
think that had a lot to do because they
were pushing him real hard Oh what's his
name was pushing Carl Carl Weathers he
was making fun of us making fun of him
for not being a Carl the best
Carl got the best I on the other hand
sly he's kind of well you know he's kind
he's a different character he's not like
a regular guy yeah you know it's lies
good kind of darker more brooding kind
of characters where there there is a
personality there that there's a lot
going on there's a lot going out it's
still his deep right but the rock can
play here oh yeah he comes across as
just a good-natured hero and like I said
it's like I haven't seen a lot of cuz I
know he was in like a lot of The Fast
and the Furious movie so we saw him in
Hobbes and Shaw and stuff like that I
said I would have a hard time and I
don't know if he's ever played a villain
but I would have a hard time he might
have in some of the Fast & Furious
movies like some of the early ones I'm
not entirely sure cuz I've only seen the
first one I don't write but um I would
have a hard time
buying him as a villain just because you
can tell that he's just like a super
nice dude
yeah he just comes across as now you
know Superman okay he's got to be played
by kind of a Greek looking guy or you
know he's basically the the Jewish Eber
Mitch you know that's what that's who
Superman is yeah the guy who made that
character and everything he's the Jewish
even even the name you know kal-el and
jor-el that all comes back from you know
the Bible Old Testament Old Testament el
you know God but anyway the rock see all
the rock is the only kind of like non
Greco non-jewish guy who could ever play
Superman and I kind of intrigued to see
what he would do with Superman he'd make
an awesome Superman I think it would
actually yeah I mean I would be willing
to see him try it to place it just the
dogs got a lot of darker complexion but
he could [ __ ] be Superman yeah
because for me Superman so he's gonna be
kinda like Chris Reeves
but yeah Chris we didn't really have the
physicality this Superman needed yeah
yeah no man the rock is pretty close
true that same khana good natured well
how you doing Lois you know you know the
rock could do that I know I'm imagining
yeah yeah yeah I think that we could
they'd probably have to put hair on him
though yeah otherwise you could be he'd
be old Superman though Superman really
okay
Superman should really be more like 35
yeah seems like he should just be kind
of the third perfectly right yeah he's
great at the prime of his the idea is
he's a perfect greco-roman statue typos
that Zuzu Duran is yeah but I think the
rock is the only only guy that could
pull that off
Jamie I think yes and I'd be like yeah
that's Superman yeah okay well yes
anyway yeah go see this movie yeah do
you mind you the next level like I said
I think I like the first one slightly
more but this one you know it's similar
in tone to the first one you know they
just kind of switch the characters not
for the whole movie like they switch
back to their regular things but shout
out to Jack Black
for channeling a black man and a girl
and doing it like really really yeah I
always liked Jack Black's work seems
like a nice dude - I don't know
not be I don't know but he just always
comes a cup comes across is very like
good nature thank you yeah maybe I kind
of I kind of suspect he's he's a guy
that once he gets a few drinks in him or
maybe a couple lines he'd drive you up
the wall probably just just for a few
minutes man just be quiet
carriers yeah there's just too much it's
like to a tree down bro it's like they
have too many drinks and they start
talking about their bottle or yeah he
gets mad at you he turns on you and
starts [ __ ] saying [ __ ] up [ __ ]
man don't make me beat up Majan that
you'd never live it down for you beat up
jagbag
the repetition to be [ __ ] ruined
although it would be funny that if he
came back later in his life [ __ ]
outfit yeah yeah there's a lot of street
cred yeah so if you like the first cheap
mange the Jumanji movie um this pretty
much like more the same but yeah kind of
different it switched up its have an 80s
throwback movie I had to try that
eighties tone yes better with the cranky
old characters like added in the mix
which is yeah always delightful very
traditional writing very traditional few
good layout it's just it's not
controversial it's you go there you have
a good [ __ ] time yeah it's just a fun
yes long walk outside drastic park you
walk out yeah it was well we were there
actually it's weird because we waited
like a really long time to see its it
had already been playing for like two or
three weeks I think we saw it and it was
still full back it was like the middle
of the day and like a whole bunch of
people have like brought their kids and
yeah [ __ ] ton of kids and no you
couldn't hear a peep from him so that
lets you know they loved ya they were
super into it I didn't hear a peep out
of them but yeah so go check that one
you
all right and third movie we saw this
week he knew we were gonna get around to
seeing this one we saw Star Wars the
rise of Scott Walker yeah boy I was
expecting a dumpster fire especially
after the last Jedi but I gotta say I
think JJ might have saved it because it
made the other two movies make a lot of
sense yeah and I know the thing we're
making this up as they were going along
but they did a good job of making it up
well yeah that's like I said that's what
you got to do and see the movie shot
really well it's it's non-stop action
yeah it's pretty much there is really
not a dull moment
right it's paced really well I liked the
pacing was very good JJ wrote stuff and
gave time to allow the new characters to
develop their characters a little bit
more so you get to the end there's more
acting in this one yeah I would say
acting real acting if it's real acting
and Star Wars is kind of like a rarity
and the edits are too fast yeah so
they're acting as much as they can
yeah I wasn't a big fan of Ray in the
last Jedi I was force awakens there the
characters are being introduced so I
would cut that one a lot of slack I like
to force awake yeah I did too
I didn't expect them to totally develop
all those characters yeah that's just
the first place that was just the first
yeah everybody knew that a trilogy
coming and it was just setting up they
were just introducing the characters in
the last Jedi the last Jedi I didn't
like what happened in it and it just I
thought the tone was wrong and no I
walked out of that one [ __ ] mad I
thought it was a wasted opportunity in
this one it this one i doesn't retcon
what happens in in the second one but it
does kind of smooth over and explain
certain things that happened yeah I
didn't get the feeling that it was
trying to like retcon or say oh that
didn't happen
right they were just kind of like
expanding on why that happen or why a
particular thing up you know what I mean
it's like I think he did a really good
job like him and the other screenwriters
I think they did a really good job cuz I
know people I didn't mind the last Jedi
like I said other than the only thing I
would have changed about last Jedi was
maybe take out that Cantor bright
sequence see his dad just because I
thought it didn't really need to be
there it didn't like advance the plot or
anything no I didn't have a problem with
it otherwise but I can't Oh bright
showed up i man I went wait a minute
hold on this is prequel territory yes
why are we going back to the worst of
stormy maybe that's what he was trying
to do you're trying to get a callback to
like the prequels though it was like all
with the goofy aliens and the goofiness
you know the Maine and space horses and
little kids [ __ ] levitate and [ __ ]
it's just it was like the worst oh say
The Phantom Menace like the Phantom
Menace racing scene the two-headed
announcer the goofy [ __ ] aliens I
hate that I still hate the phantom the
Phantom Menace has some problems there
was some good stuff there but it was
just it had some the prequels in general
I occasionally am NOT a fan of I like
Revenge of the Sith but it's still like
a problematic film The Phantom Menace I
can barely sit through it Lucas has a
problem this bad habit of being very
Lucas e yeah and you know that one's
more Lucas e than a no he's a lucca
theist new hope was saved in the Edit
because a lot of the Lucas E stuff went
out the second one and Lucas really
didn't have a lot to do with that as
much they had other guys that were
directing and British guys that were
taking it seriously shooting in like a
world war ii flick and then it goes into
them return to the Jedi and Lucas is
back in there he keeps some of the good
stuff from you know Empire Strikes Back
but he gets Lucas he again you know
nobody with the watch my me walks but
they were a little sound so much of the
you have none all that you know on the
soundtrack and just it just and then
certain stuff on the sand barge and
throw them boba fett down inside the
sand but hole all that [ __ ] just wasted
this wasted good character
wasting Darth Maul and wisdom [ __ ] I
mean just waste [ __ ] they come up with
Boba Fett and Darth Maul to the coolest
character in a way that's like yeah it's
like they're in the movie for like five
minutes
dark ball should have been an all three
prequel movie I should have died a Dan I
think he should have been like the a or
be it now yes right Darth Maul cuz like
I said you don't come look something
cool as [ __ ] like that and then just be
like oh he's done you should have
thought he should have thought that
Darth Maul was in charge of this that he
was the main SIF at the very end you
find out that [ __ ] Palpatine is the
Emperor I mean you know but everybody
else is supposed to go well with the
whole the whole time here there we're
gonna go oh then no I mean that the Jedi
shouldn't have known until the very last
movie yeah you know okay should have
been North mall through the whole thing
anyway let's go back to this one I think
JJ did it did the best a human could
possibly do with with the two films that
had come before it
yeah I couldn't see in any other way I
liked the Rey character and the Finn in
the poker the new characters I liked him
a little bit more in this one well they
were liked a little more flavor a little
more fleshed out so I liked a little bit
more they felt like characters in a Star
Wars movie yeah
the first one the other two it's kind of
like they were token characters they
weren't really developing that that well
I didn't think yeah especially in last
Jedi some of stuff that happened with in
the mutiny and the the slow-motion space
chase to go back and get fuel and we got
to find a Code Breaker we better leave
this base break go to the go to the
casino
it just didn't [ __ ] make any sense
like I said here's the thing like I know
that people are gonna piss and moan
either way Star Wars and Star Wars fans
or [ __ ] yeah and they just complain
about everything hey I'm Star Wars but I
but I can explain it I didn't like I
said I didn't mind the last Jedi um you
know there was a couple weird decisions
in there but I'm just like whatever man
you know man how they handled
I didn't but well they explained all
that but see that's what I mean and the
reason that I didn't get butthurt about
it
was that I'm like one it's the second
movie in a trilogy it's like I'm not
gonna [ __ ] until I see where they're
going with it right I want to see what
they're gonna do with it you know so I
feel like now that the whole I mean this
movie it's like I said either people are
gonna complain that it's like oh it's
retcons because of the second one or
they're gonna complain that it's too
much fanservice or something it's like
they're gonna find something to whine
about I will say that I actually really
I thought this movie was pretty [ __ ]
great um I had a [ __ ] blast watching
it it just it just moves right along
everything is you know plotted really
well it goes like from one thing to the
next like you know what I mean
everything looks great yeah it's a
gorgeous looking movie good sound good
good good soundtrack and it's good the
acting is good you know I mean yeah like
a lot of acting in between and it's so
like a lot of the stuff that they did in
this movie really brought like a lot of
resonance yeah to stuff that was in
force awakens in last Jedi yeah you know
it so it kind of gives it like weight
retro actively retro actively it
retroactively lease cleans up a lot of
problems you know the mini game went
back in time and cleaned up and
explained some stuff that happened while
Luke did certain things and like I know
they made it up as they went along but
JJ did a good job of making this story
up and I was expecting a dumps dumpster
fire I was pissed I was I was ready to
walk I was opposite and prepare myself
this is gonna [ __ ] be just as pissed
or more pissed than [ __ ] last Jedi
well see this I was not into it this is
why I was not looking forward to seeing
cuz I didn't want to like listen to him
come I was a half hour yeah I was a half
hour into it not leaned over Genesis
this is huge approve it yeah I proved it
alright and there's a lot of expense
there's gonna be people complaining now
they brought the Emperor back they did
this they did that word all these
[ __ ] weird this week come from well
if you look at the EU you know there was
some there was some extended or
something
Banta universe stuff where the emperor
did come back and had a series of clones
he had the force abilities to dam
astrally project and possess bodies
that's there that's already in Star Wars
that's what I mean that's to make
anything up everything was from the
exciting and if you played Knights of
the Old Republic and Sith Lords
there's [ __ ] like plants like Korriban
stuff like the star Forge with the star
Forge was a damn SIF machine that ran
off the dark side of the force
that could just make armies of armies of
ships just out of nothing yeah yeah and
they were kind of AI they didn't explain
if all those damn Star Destroyer
Sawyer's if they were all fully manned
or not I just assumed well because the
way they kind of just came up out of
nowhere they didn't working on him for a
long time there wasn't a lot of people
though yeah on that planet so I just
thought most of them were probably just
AI robotic yeah ships which would make
them which would make more sense you
know some of them had people like the
command ships but I think most of them
didn't have [ __ ] crew automata Suman
yeah it doesn't matter it was just it
looked cool yeah and you had stuff like
that in Knights of the Old Republic and
then you had a bunch of cool Sith stuff
yeah that is kind of like something out
of the game Sith Lords which that was
one of the things that I really I mean I
have to say like out of this trilogy and
like I said I wasn't one of those people
that was like whining about last Jedi or
anything like that I really liked force
awakens last Jedi I didn't mind it I
like I said other than that one sequence
they probably could have taken out
because it was kind of useless I didn't
really have a problem with it this one I
think is my well actually I don't think
I know this was this is my favorite one
of this trilogy yeah and actually I like
this one
so I like this one the best of this
trilogy it blows all the [ __ ]
prequels out of the water I would say so
cuz those are just mostly terrible I cut
him some slack
I cut the prequels some slack there is
good material in there it needs to be
edited well I could take those three
movies and edit it into two buddy I
can't remember who it was but somebody I
don't know if they ended it all three of
the prequels but I know they did Phantom
Menace and like I watched their edit
like it was a fan at it and it was great
yeah so it just goes to show it wasn't
just everything's Indiana it was as a
[ __ ] they filmed it was just like how
they cut it all too
in there and what they left in and when
they could have left
in a way return RCB Revenge of this
Revenge of the Sith kind of redeemed the
prequels yeah I mean I think it did
because it had real good [ __ ] with you
know Palpatine panting save that movie
yeah all right [ __ ] stuff yeah lord
Vader you know that kind of stuff help
rise so like I said it's just well it's
just that you know I mean go after
you've killed all the Jedi it'll be
strong enough in a dark side to save
Padme and I was like oh man you gotta go
kill all those little kids and then
you'll be strong enough with evil to do
this [ __ ] anyway this movie Kanna this
movie Kanna redeems I think Dean I think
it saves the well like I said that just
stays waiting I was kind of like like I
liked the other two movies but I was
reserving judgment until I could see the
whole trilogy because I just like I said
I want to see where the story's got one
I want to see what you're doing with
this um you know and like I said I'm
sure like you know half the fans will
[ __ ] cry but um I actually really
liked this movie there was no part of it
that was boring it was [ __ ] great
looking of all the acting was good there
was some humor in it but it wasn't goofy
or over-the-top yeah um you know no
goofiness that was good
yeah it's like you know there there
weren't like you know crazy aliens or
anybody talking and weird racial staring
it's like you know what I mean it was
just like a good like adventure story
there were high stakes I liked all the
you know there's like a really lot of
like cool Sith stuff in this yeah which
I'm so it gave it like a really dark
like kind of yeah gothic kind of va to
it which I really dug um some of the for
the force powers that they show or in
the video games yeah like a force bond
where you have two Jedi there yeah cuz
that - of course - force users they're
not even related can somehow get in a
relationship or one learn something and
the other one learns it - yeah and then
they kind of the synergy plays off the
two of them and then they can kind of
appear to each other or absolutely
project to each other it's that stuff's
in the video games yes
so if anybody like that's just Lucas
that just knows about the movies is like
pissing him - Lego brought wasn't in the
movies but that was like a lot of it is
in expand expanded universe stuff so
it's I don't think there's anything in
this movie that hasn't been referred to
elsewhere it's like it's nothing that
like anybody pulled out of their ass or
anything like that it's all makes sense
it's all like in Canon um so and you
have to think I mean I mean blush JJ
Abrams because it's like I would not
want a [ __ ] task like wrapping up
this repetitious Naga and like not just
these this trilogy but pretty much the
whole thing yeah and just kind of trying
to wrap it up in a way that's like
really satisfying and I think he did a
really good job yeah I was gonna I was
expecting a dumpster fire I didn't
really think he had it any I heard a lot
of stuff online people talking about the
movie with the problems it had I saw
what it is they're talking about those
aren't problems or they're very small
problems yeah they're making they're
making a mountain out of mole hills oh
yeah or they don't know the video games
very well oh it's it's it's - this is a
cannon movie yeah and I just trying
anything he's trying to wrap everything
up after the last Jedi I still don't
like last Jedi but with this new movie
you can go back and reinterpret
everything in the first two movie yeah
and it makes a lot more sense because
that's what it was written was written
to make that third one explained it I
don't think that those I don't think
that's what the original intent was but
he didn't explain it that way so it did
work yeah and it's the last Jedi more
understandable and really I mean the
thing about it is one it's like a
fictional story and so even if that
wasn't the intention like with the last
Jedi maybe he wanted to go to I mean he
knew that he wasn't gonna be directing
the third when he knew that JJ Abrams
was gonna do it so he just wanted to do
his own thing and it's like that's fine
like I said I like Rian Johnson should
we just saw knives out well that was
really good it also explains Snoke I
forgot to say that yes plain but so yeah
but like I said it's kind of like it's
kind of like that game where everybody
is like you know writing down a
paragraph and then you pass it to the
person behind you and then they have to
just keep continuing with the story it's
like like I said it's a fictional story
you have to make it up like within
certain parameters otherwise like I said
all everybody's gonna cry because it's
like not a Canon and stuff
but you know I can see how some people
are criticizing because like oh it seems
like he reckoned everything that was in
the second one but I don't I wouldn't
call it right I'm not really ready he
didn't say it's this movie is not saying
it's like nothing in the last Jedi
happened it is an explanation
it just gives an explanation for why
things in that movie happened the way
they happened yeah and I think it was a
pretty satisfying like explanation and I
think it was a pretty satisfying
conclusion
yeah to like the whole thing kind of
made you tear up at time yeah it's like
they had some fanservice ii stuff in
there like some you know some old
buddies and stuff like turning up and
everything but not in a way that was
like obnoxious yeah I didn't find it
particularly obnoxious
yes strangely enough for as kind of
convoluted as this had to be to explain
everything it's one of the more natural
feeling Star Wars movies that's what I
meant when I would say a lot better than
the prequels some of those prequels were
pretty unnatural and wouldn't feeling
and actually return to the Jedi I had
times that were pretty kind of wonky
feeling this is I think maybe like a
little bit better than Return of the
Jedi I was just gonna say that yeah am I
gonna get struck down by somebody I like
the internet gods for saying it's like
why use I'm I might like this if I
haven't seen in Return of the Jedi and a
couple of years I think this one it
doesn't have some of the hook units that
return the Jedi yeah it's like and I'm
not one of the people that see what it's
doing all it can to be kind of like
Empire Strikes Back tone yeah which
Empire Strikes Back was kind of things
portrayed with a bit of realism well
that's a good tone to anything that was
the tone that I think they were going
for like I said this is I like like all
of the dark [ __ ] yes because it's a lot
of sit [ __ ] in here yeah and you know
I'm not gonna give away like the big
reveals and it's not really pulled out
of the ass it's there and all the
[ __ ] you know video games but
Lucasfilm made the good ones you know
yeah except Lourdes and it's what this
is or what they're supposed to be know
and they come out and write to say that
you know this is a [ __ ] pathway to
[ __ ] that's all natural yeah
you know I mean these [ __ ]
cheap and the main thing is to have
cheat death yeah you know
and the power over life and death yeah
and that's what they're doing and then
unlimited creation of things yeah you
know so that's that's like a large part
of this movie yeah you know what I mean
like I said I don't want to give away
any like big in the final battle the way
it all happens it's satisfying you can
kind of say you don't want that you know
that was kind of an abbreviated version
um you just have to make you it I would
say the end scene the final fight scene
it's it's artistic I would say that that
was portrayed in a common artistic yeah
not very realistic I think but more
artistic yeah
like the fight scene out of the last
Jedi where they were on the bridge and
Snoke got killed yeah that was actually
one of the better fight scenes I've ever
I'd seen in a Star Wars movie yeah that
looked pretty good wasn't that that
level but the meaning of it was a better
I think yeah but you know like I said
you can go back and reinterpret the last
Jedi a different way now knowing what
you know with this one yeah I mean the
thing about it is like every time it's
just like every time a new Star Wars
trilogy comes out it's like it always
seems like everybody says oh it's
divisive it's like every time it's
divisive and I feel like oh I remember
when the LAT when the prequels came out
and that was pretty divisive they say
the Mandalorian is getting universal I
still need to watch that guys really
good as good as the Mandalorians going
and I think this movie we'll end up
doing vert will do well I think that the
word of mouth actually in will be I
think it'll actually get better we
actually yeah it's like I asked impact I
think the word of mouth will get better
yeah and it's been planned for like a
few I mean we wanted to wait till after
Christmas and stuff and we went inside
it like 11:45 in the morning um you know
so like on a weekday but it was still it
was pretty full and when we went to the
theater to see Jumanji I think on the
day that it opened and on the only day
that star wars opened and there were as
a million people in there and a lot of
them had kids so I feel like that's you
know and the little kids were like in
their little outfits and you know they
had the little costumes on and
everything so there was like a [ __ ] ton
of like people seeing this
so like I said I feel like you know
maybe this is true of everything but
it's like I I kind of get sick of all
the whining and outrage and stuff like
that about this kind of crap well
there's a lot of money lying an outrage
but well I know but it's not
entertainment it that's why they do it
well I know I'm like but like I said I'm
not entertained by it but I guess some
people are yeah well good to me it just
gives me a headache
but um but I you know that's probably
like a small proportion of vocal people
that are like oh I don't like it because
of this or I don't like it because of
that like I said you can't really win
it's like you know everybody was like
you know people that bitched about the
force awakens were like oh it was too
much like a new hope so then they made
of the last Jedi it's like oh that's too
different I like it anymore so now it's
like this one comes out and it's like oh
it's either
oh it's retconned or oh it's slightly
fancier or it's all fanservice or it's
like I said they're just gonna find
something whine about regardless but
it's like you know just aside from all
that like I think this movie is actually
gonna do pretty well this is it's the
best one this is a really entertaining
it's like really crowd-pleasing it's
gets dark it's got dark scary kind of
[ __ ] in it it's like yeah a really cool
to look at it really fast-paced look
there's a lot of battles and there's a
lot of fighting and this like and it's
just like a really really good [ __ ]
movie it's like it hardly slows down I
mean there's a few like character scenes
you know the develop the relationship
between Rey and kylo Ren is like really
kind of deepened and like you know they
go a lot more into that and like it's
better than all the prequels and it's
the best one out of the new series yeah
easily yeah I want to say it's better
than last Jedi but it's it's it's it's
there it's getting there it's it's it is
because it's a newer movie I would say
it's better than that technically what
you mean Return of the Jedi return the
gym deadlift yeah return the Jedi it's
better than Return of the Jedi think
technically it's not well it's not a
classic but like I said it's it's a good
movie I was pretty surprised with it I
think it will do better than the last
Jedi at the box office I don't know if
it'll do force awakens numbers that was
that movie was [ __ ] huge yeah because
there was excited but over time I think
the movie will be appreciated
I didn't take time well like I said
that's kind of what now here's the crazy
thing is like I decided I was like I
don't watch reviews before I watch the
movie like sometimes I'll read them
after like before we do the show and
everything it's like it seems like a lot
of people are really like pissing and
moaning about this movie in that can
they really hated it and like some
people even said and this is crazy talk
that this trilogy that they hated this
whole trilogy so much that it made the
prequel trilogy look better I'm like you
are high the prequels are terrible
they're still terrible I just saw them
yeah a year or two ago and they're still
did not age well they're still bad they
weren't very good when it came out and
they didn't age for this freak this
trilogy was way way better [ __ ]
prequels yeah and it's like if you think
I don't know what the hell is the matter
with you if you think I'm yeah retro
actively and now that the class Jedi got
cleaned up that's a yeah this is better
than a prequel series yeah I mean those
are just not good movies other than
Revenge of the Sith was half of a good
movie the other two were they were all
kind of half a good movies through the
prequels like I said you could take
those three movies and edit it into two
pretty good movies yeah I think the
reason I hated Phantom Menace so much
was just because it was mostly about a
kid a kid and I was like hey any aliens
are charged thanks
oh yeah killed off into a coma which was
the best thing about the movie which was
the coolest thing um and qui-gon got
killed in it which he was good in the
movie too
yeah so like all your boats yeah obi-wan
yeah it was pretty much the only good
thing about that jet yeah so but it's
like because I love you in McGregor but
you know what I mean it's like so
anybody that would think that the
prequels were actually better than this
trilogy has nipples in a while I don't
know because the prequels they're just I
don't know there's I think I think I
think over time this I think over time
like you know gets their panties out of
their ass and I think the Mandalorian
will save all this because they seem to
be loved in the Mandalorian I have not
heard a single bound you said about the
Mandalorian and over time I think
they'll kind of retroactively like oh
yeah that was okay too and then you know
new fans maybe it's hard to say it's
harder that's what I mean and that's in
a way like that's kind of why I was like
Mayall like internet whining is probably
not gonna make any difference because
when we were at the theater like seeing
Jumanji and Star Wars had just opened it
was like a [ __ ] ton of kids yeah and
they all had their little Star Wars
outfits on and they were super jazzed
yeah so it's you know so like I said
some forty it's like not gonna make
speaking of I had one of them next to me
who's doing this the whole time he was
really every time I look I'm like dude
man you're [ __ ] 40 no what I was
gonna say about Phantom Menace and stuff
like that cuz remember like this is why
I couldn't stand Rob Zombie's Halloween
remake because I was like I don't want
to see Michael Myers is like a poor
little abuse child that I sympathize
with he's not scary then I don't want to
see Darth Vader as a little kid yeah who
the [ __ ] thought that was a good idea
that whole storyline I've done knows it
did think it did a whole video I but
they ended a whole video on this one
time the whole storyline of the prequels
was done and not in the best way there
should have been a Jedi Civil War that's
what was originally described yeah and
it should have been two factions of good
Jedi accusing each other of being
traitors and it was Darth Maul as though
much finer as Darth Maul doing all this
and he was like fomenting well he was
the one that they knew about secretly it
was Palpatine who was friends of the
Jedi okay
and then he ended up getting Anakin to
hunt down all these other Jedi because
he thought they were traitors all along
but turned out he was on the wrong side
yeah that he was being full and that
should have been that just that short
description yeah and it's like a way
better right and he should have been the
damned best
Jedi out of them all all the way for
like a movie and a half yeah alright and
then the other movie in and a half
he's [ __ ] started to slowly slide and
and actually in that last movie he's
Darth Vader
yeah he should be been in that suit and
everything yeah last one that's what
like that's I think that's the reason
that like the Phantom Menace I really
hate because it's like and don't like I
said nobody
to see Darth Vader nobody's need to see
Anakin Skywalker's a little kid it's
like why didn't they start it like uh
you know the the story of him his
descent to the darkside that's an
interesting story right but don't you
know to start it when he's little it's
like everybody's a [ __ ] teenager his
descent in the dark side and the
prequels last in about 20-30 minutes
that's what I mean that should have been
we're gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] with him out
of a young Darth Vader running around in
that damn suit hunting people down with
John rockin trilogy drivin and he should
have been he should have been fighting
there should have been a fight with
between him and you obi-wan when they
were young and Vader in this suit yeah
already dry Vader that way goes oh we
meet again that way that would have made
more sense way cooler way cooler
so again prequel [ __ ] ahead meme right
now [ __ ] story I wrote this [ __ ] out
[Laughter]
so seriously anybody anybody that says
the prequels are better than this truly
now yeah that's great now they made a
lot raising a lot of mistakes in the
story I mean you know it's like all of
the movies even the classic ones had
missteps you know what I mean um but I
really really liked his move there
wasn't really any of it that I didn't
like there was nothing in it that it was
just like I'm Jace or whatever um like I
said it was really enjoyable there are
problems even in the classics yeah
that's what I'm saying so it's like and
and and a new hope is not perfect it's
good it's damn good yeah the perfect
Star Wars movie was the Empire Strikes
and that straight backs back and that
really didn't have a Lucas doing
everything in it you know yeah that was
British guys making that yeah but you
need somebody's telling no yeah and but
the perfect Star Wars movie was Empire
Strikes Back
yeah well and like I said that will
probably always be I don't know if
you're gonna be able to make the Star
Wars may be better than Empire Strikes
Back right but this one was an attempt
but this one what yet and like I said if
you're gonna [ __ ] say save Tom Mann
reach for it it was kind of that same
tone it was I mean it hit a lot of the
same days and a little bit of Return of
the Jedi in it too
like not goofy [ __ ] but um the best
parts of but the best parts attractive
and also the best parts of a Revenge of
the Sith were in it
yeah a lot of the Sith stuff yeah
better I think that was my favorite
thing about this like the the really
like there's a lot of likes yeah what
the sender did yeah and I and I really
dug that and I really dug like water
more sorry yeah like I really dug all
the imagery and I was like actually
surprised cuz like I said I did not read
anything about this movie before cuz I
just wanted to like watch it without any
preconceptions and so I wasn't expecting
like such a sit focus and I was like oh
I'm I'm on board with this yes like
pretty good yeah it starts off with kylo
Ren and [ __ ] he was doing yeah it was
like man all right and I tell you what
Adam driver to kylo Ren really was for
me throughout the entire three movies
kylo Ren was the most interesting
character yeah I thought he's more
interesting array and isn't it the other
one those other characters really didn't
get too interesting until this movie
until this one yeah so Adam actually
carried this whole trilogy yeah when he
was always really good actor but he was
on screen I was always paying attention
no matter no matter what movie it was
yeah so really he was the shining light
of this whole damn well villains are
always interesting and he's really good
at this and and Daisy Ridley because I
think of that what they gave her to do
in the lines and and that character got
a lot better
well they gave her a lot of depth dia um
and a lot of you know like I said I
don't try I'm trying to think of a word
to use that won't like spoil it maybe I
kept a lot better yeah they know they
allowed her do do more stuff and the
same thing with Poe and Finn that they
allowed those they allowed them to act
they gave him a stuff to do and they and
you could tell like um because here was
another thing that I saw people bitching
about there's like oh well at the
beginning of this movie like Oh
everyone's besties all of a sudden I'm
like yeah but some time has passed yeah
from the end of the last Jedi to now so
it's like yeah they're friends you know
what I mean it's like it's not that
weird I didn't find it that weird so I
really got like even when the movie
starts you get the weight that you know
of the friendship that's gone on like in
between movies you know what I mean so
that's how I took it I didn't take it as
like Oh suddenly they're all best
friends because I didn't I don't know I
thought that was a weird criticism yeah
I didn't agree with everything was down
these past three movies but this one did
save the other two movies yeah like I
said this really kind of retro like I
said it really tied everything up really
nicely not just this trilogy but cuz I
don't see how JJ could have done you
better
I really don't either it's like I was
trying to think like during the thing
and I was just sitting there going well
it's like you know what if I wanted to
read yeah it's like this is really the
best possible yeah movie that he could
have made yeah yeah hey and it's a good
[ __ ] movie I really like that's good
just pretty good I really I liked it
yeah see Tom liked it yeah how do you
think I would I was like worried about
it I was like oh man please just be good
please let yeah well yeah I really liked
it like I said this is probably gonna be
like force awakens so I did have some
hope that maybe JJ could save it yeah
that's true
he did but yeah we'll see you like I
said it's gonna be divisive I'm sure cuz
yeah
cuz but it's out on our really Doggett
all right so since this is the last
matinee of 2019 thought I'd do a little
bonus and my favorite movies of the year
I'm gonna pick them now keep in mind
that I watched a lot of other people's
top ten lists and like I was reading
through hermits there's a lot of movies
that were on people's list that I
haven't seen yet a marriage story that
was one that comes up atom drivers in
that as well that's on Netflix haven't
seen that yet haven't seen uncut gems it
is playing at our theater I'll probably
see it next week 19:17 because it hasn't
started here yet little women Jojo
rabbit ad astra stuff like that so we
haven't seen any of those I know those
have come up on a lot of people's lists
so don't like you know use that as a way
to say that it's like oh you know those
must not be good movies I just haven't
seen them yet now I'm gonna start out
with some this was kind of hard um oh we
saw actually some pretty good movies
this year and initially at a top 20 and
I was like that's kind of stupid but
it's like I decided to do a top 10 and
then just do some honorable mentions
yeah mile probably be the same services
we usually grab similar maybe the order
might not be the same see now here my
honorable mentions and like I said
initially at a top 20 so it's like it
was hard for me to put him in order so
not like it's uber order honorable
mentions doctor sleep Apollo 11 best
documentary we saw this year usually
they shall not grow old also a
documentary was that that was the one
that was amazing yeah
these are all like really good movies
like I really like these it's just they
weren't there wasn't room for them in
the doctor waiting what was number 10
what wait am I done okay I'm still do an
honorable mention it's still yeah okay
like I said there was a lot of movies I
like this year
ready or not dolomite is my name yeah
fighting with my family yeah John wick 3
yeah Elita battle angel yeah Shazam
yeah one cut of the dead yeah the hole
in the ground Tigers are not afraid
Rocket Man the headhunter and I am
mother I'd take Rocket Man
I liked Rocket Man a lot well this is my
list yeah but not here like that alright
so here are my top ten oh like I said
this is kind of hard it's like there's
sort of an order number ten
Hotel Mumbai I don't see a lot of people
like talking about this movie but I
really really liked that movie it's
played in the theater yeah and it's like
that it just kind of disappeared right
it was really good really really
realistic and really tense I was like I
was just like biting my nails the whole
time and it's really weird that I feel
like people like I guess it came out
like a while back but it's like I feel
like people kind of forgot about it in
their top chance I don't think I saw it
on anybody else's top ten list but I
actually really liked it so that's my
number ten my number nine is the
irishman which we just watched the other
day the Martin Scorsese movie I thought
that was just okay yeah I mean you know
it is at number eight all right
number eight us the Jordan Peele movie
which I really liked very much uh number
seven uh but Star Wars at number seven
Oh guys this guy Walker seven my number
six was midsummer the re-ask oh yeah
yeah I don't
yeah I don't think I'd have that one up
there either number five but we did
differ on a lot of that stuff yes
yeah v 4v Ferrari yeah I really really
liked a lot uh number four actually I
think I just did eleven movies I well
over knives out number I have two number
fours okay so this is a top 11 okay so
my other number four I just noticed my
other number four for Joker yeah fine
number three parasite yeah number two
the lighthouse
yeah I really [ __ ] liked that movie
and number one Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood was probably my favorite movie
this year okay
mine would have been one lead a battle
Angela yeah I figured okay to probably
would have been Joker yeah okay um let
me see can you see what you have
three would have been John twig yeah
okay I pretty I loved every single movie
that I yeah for probably would have been
like Shazam
no no dolomite is my name and then
Shazam yeah that makes five I think
right there
yeah I think so um Apollo 11 and then
dr. sleep so three more would probably
be something like hmm did you like the
rainbow yeah
Rambo would be there yeah Rambo and the
UH Bohemian Rhapsody that was last year
does last year I think so yeah because
when I was looking at real cuz I've
looked through all our old matinees and
then I looked through and I would have
to have Ford versus Ferrari yeah and
once upon a time in Hollywood yeah
that'd be might that be my top two so
you know we had about half and actually
that order may not be perfect yeah all
that is way best ones this year and it
just depends on what mood you're in
and that's the thing too it's like
that's why I was gonna do a top twenty
and I was like cuz that's why I have so
many honorable mentions because it's
like man I saw a lot of movies that I
really liked it I probably put star wars
in that top 10 - yeah that's what I mean
it's like we just saw it today so yeah I
thought that was gonna be it I killed
that actually that actually pushed dr.
sleep off my time yes I'd like to talk
to dr. sleep also I did as well like I
said every single one that I mentioned
in the honorable mentions were all
awesome movies - and it was really hard
for me to pick I don't really like artsy
fartsy movies too much so yeah White
House we submit summer I enjoyed them at
the time but they don't ever go to my my
best yeah I actually kind of like I'm
almost thinking about maybe Jumanji the
next level should have been in there too
so yeah I like a blockbuster feel-good
type movies those always move to the top
for me yeah you know I like those yeah I
just got pedestrian tastes I just go for
escapism I love a stamp ISM you know
yeah and one one that wasn't on here was
I totally forgot about Avengers I'm like
but I was kind of like I remember liking
it when we saw it but it's like that I'm
not like a huge Marvel fans person so
it's like they don't really they're
enjoyable but they don't stick with me
well hi there Pookie I actually like
these last couple DC movies better than
the moral stuff although I didn't tell
like that also I have to say that the
new Wonder Woman that's coming out looks
good that it looks pretty good got a
seat got a scene like a Wonder Woman 84
or whatever yeah I got to see the old
one a woman and black widows getting
around you - I know that's myrtle yeah
that looked like real Wonder Woman in
the butt and the red red blue and cold
[ __ ] I got the other Wonder Woman
even though I've everyone's told me that
it's good but I haven't got around to
seeing it yet um cuz like I said I've
you know it he doesn't like arty-farty
but I like arty-farty movies and I also
like I like all kind of movies I'll
pretty much give anything a chance um
but kind of the bigger epic like
superhero ones I'll usually like just
wait until they're on Netflix or
something then I'll watch them it's
never like the first priority cuz it's
like cuz one there's a million horror
movie is that I still have to watch so
horror movies are always first priority
Joker was a badass super villain movie
it was okay that wasn't like a superhero
that was just a movie movie that I mean
it was a film that was [ __ ] cinema
yeah yeah no talk about that's what I
liked about it it wasn't like a
realistic kind of gritty no Shazam's a
flick and really that's like I like this
if I really like session that's the tone
that I like I just [ __ ] hilarious and
I had a good time and the rock was
behind that mountain testosterone heeelp
produced that movie I remember I just
like thank you guys I know you guys like
we're already working on a sequel
remember I jus member like what we were
going to see that and I thought it would
be okay like the trailers looked pretty
cool and everything but we did yeah um I
actually ended up liking it a lot more
than I thought I was going to Sam that
was one of my biggest surprises of the
year as far as superhero movie goes here
oh I like that Shazam yeah well because
I liked it because he was just like this
funny a regular well he wasn't even a
dude he was a kid and it's like they got
a lot of comic mileage out of that and
and I really bought him as a kid in a
superhero by that's exactly what a kid
in a superhero box by diverse wasn't bad
that was last year last year I think
that was end of last year so yeah if
if this had been like last year's movies
that dibs would definitely have been
yeah I gotta get you Sam on blu-ray yeah
we definitely should I gets out yeah
yeah but so she's a my blu-ray I want to
get that maybe maybe we'll get Wonder
Woman or something yeah cause like I
said I need to see there's there's even
like a [ __ ] ton of like Marvel movies I
haven't seen either I still haven't seen
Black Panther I saw him saying like
there's a [ __ ] ton of movies I haven't
seen so you know I tried to get around
to him I'm like I said there's ones that
I've been hearing like a lot of people
put on their top-10 lists like
particularly uncut gems that the Adam
Sandler movie where and everyone's like
you guys need to see that because that's
like a masterpiece it is playing at the
theater here or at least it was
yesterday um it might not stay too long
cuz it's one of its AMC artisan films
okay that's very funny it's like not
like regular movies these are like yeah
but yeah so I kind of want to see that
so you know but this this is the top ten
and the honorable mentions of the movies
that I've seen so far on the record yeah
and even her already movies they were
good doing good I liked him I just
didn't put him up there like him in the
top once yes then wasn't there the
artist self-defense to was the yes yeah
yeah yeah never that one and that was an
art that was already film about [ __ ]
kung foo yeah and and the ridiculousness
of [ __ ] comfo if you liked our show
on [ __ ] Oh
fake martial arts yeah see the artist
self-defense I forgot about that is that
it that should have been in my arm
deserves a very accurate I really very
accurate depiction of a [ __ ] McDo Joe
and how she can go wrong
yeah and I like that cut it was very
like deadpan yeah where's that kind of
like I kind of want that on blu-ray I
didn't put the dead don't die in my even
though I kind of dug that a lot of
people hated that I liked it I can see
how people would hate it but I I don't
know for some reason it just tickled me
you tickled my funny bone like right in
the right place but yeah so that was the
top ten movies of the year Shirley yells
are different and that'll do it for the
last matinee of 2019 we will see you
next time
[Music]